welcome back to CBS this morning while
many focus on the intense partisanship
in Washington our new series American
Voices explores how mayors and governors
are tackling major issues on their own
today we look at Reno Nevada for decades
the city was a gambling mecca but when
casinos fell on hard times
Reno struggled the city has reinvented
itself as a tech hub thanks to recent
arrivals like Tesla the auto makers
local gigafactory for batteries expects
to hire as many as three thousand
workers this year alone jobs their
average $14 an hour well above the
state's minimum wage since Reno's
independent mayor Hillary shivi took
office in November 2014 the city's
unemployment rate has steadily declined
it now stands at four percent that is
lower than the national average and down
from almost fourteen percent in 2011
mayor CV joins us now
welcome well thank you for having me all
right team Nevada saying it correctly
Nevada is hot Reno is hotter right now
why you're exactly right well it's an
incredible time to live there certain
certainly our outdoor recreation is
phenomenal but companies like Tesla
Switch Amazon Apple Google are all
investing in building there why is that
mean we did hear the president talk
about immigration and these high high
skill highly skilled jobs what is it
about Reno that you think is selling
itself
well 320 days of sunshine to start and
when I got here this morning downpour of
rain so I was kind of asking everyone
how many days of sunshine does we don't
have but really to be honest with you
it's our proximity obviously to the bay
area medium home prices in Reno are 350
thousand one point five in San Francisco
1.5 million in San Francisco so it's
much more affordable to do business in
Reno and obviously less government
regulations has been important and so we
really we've also looked at hospitality
right so we've done a phenomenal job
reinventing ourselves
we're not just the gaming Mecca anymore
and tech companies are really realizing
that you're going to add 50,000 new jobs
in the region in just five years that's
what you've done what can other cities
learn from what you're doing in Reno
well I think cutting the government red
tape is really important when I got into
office unemployment was at 12% now we're
down to three point nine percent in Reno
and it really is about streamlining the
process and talking to them saying hey
how can we help you and government does
not do a very good job of doing that
we've certainly learned our lesson in
Nevada and it's paying off and you think
I'll going down that road a little bit
that when it comes to health care
something that any employer looks at
that Congress is moving a bit too quick
for you absolutely right now mayor's
across the country are saying hey you
really need to slow it down this is not
a partisan issue certainly for mayors
this is a people issue and it's a very
serious issue I think I can connect with
it really well because I've had a kidney
transplant I know what it's like to take
life-saving medication and I know what
it's like to see people at grocery
stores and at Little League fields that
are panicked by this and so mayor's
across the country are saying hey we
need to slow down and bring mayor's to
the table in Washington that's something
we have not been part of the process and
I will tell you the Obama administration
did that great he really sat down with
mayors we talked to cabinet members and
we were really part of the conversation
whether it's tax reform or
infrastructure bills we need to get back
to basics and it starts with mayors we
really are at Ground Zero in our cities
but the president wants to move this
along quickly right I mean he's talking
about pulling these subsidies for the
ACA subsidies well what would that mean
for a place like Reno well it absolutely
would be completely devastating we were
at one of the highest rates in the
nation of uninsured at 23% we're down
now to 12% so we know how drastic that
would be for health care in my state but
it's all across America so we're
incredibly nervous about it and I hear
these these phone calls of sheer panic
from my constituents and this is this is
very real so we are saying slow it down
bring mayor's to the table we need to be
part of that solution as well because
again we are at Ground Zero we we often
laughs mayor's laugh because there's no
democratic or republican way to clean a
street right so again that's why mayor's
are very important to be there know you
according to a 2014 study had the
highest proportion of undocumented
immigrants of any US state and the
largest share in its workforce for you
in Reno what does that mean
what are those jobs well that's huge I
mean for four families this is something
and another reason why it's so important
in Nevada we rely on tourism so heavily
as well right and so we talked about
travel bans and things like that what
his latest proposals right to reduce the
number of green cards wouldn't impact
agriculture exactly and jobs and so a
weakened incredibly nervous about that
but again hearing the sheer panic from
families that this would shatter them so
again we need to be part of this
discussion and we really haven't been to
the magnitude that we have been in the
past so we it makes us very nervous and
it's it's like I said you can hear the
sheer panic in some of my constituents
voices when they call my office because
that's the first phone call they make to
mayor's my money is on Reno there you go
we know Nevada Novak yeah I'm so
impressed
thank you for having me